we are ready for your questions
Jason is ready Mike is right there if
you can get up and go to that mic that
would be fantastic you guys have a good
time tonight yeah good good I'm really
happy to hear that
all right this question hey thanks I
really wanted to talk about the VR
theater idea that you had there wasn't
what VR VR in theater we are in theater
okay yeah cool performances and virtual
reality I was wondering if you could
expand upon that sure um have you ever
read a book called Hamlet on the
holodeck Hamlet and the holodeck
no okay so Janet Marie wrote this book
the holodeck from Star Trek you know
that room where you go and it's a so
Hamlet on the holodeck is a book about
immersion which is the the word that we
use to describe that magical feeling
when you assume the mediated reality so
it's you know you go to a theatre and
you're you kind of restless like when is
this gonna start and you know and then
you're like you have to pee and you know
it starts and you're still thinking
about work and whatever and then like if
it's good right if the acting is good if
the thing is music is good if whatever
is good if you didn't eat too much
you're not too full or whatever all of a
sudden like all that other [ __ ] you were
worried about gone and now you're like
fully [ __ ] investors in the narrative
like as far as I'm concerned that's the
holy grail of media when it immerses you
fully and the better the media the more
satiating and satisfying the immersion
so now we you know it already exists to
a certain degree a good movie is
brilliantly immersive a good play is
brilliantly immersive because we can
broadcast our mind from the seat into
the screen or into the stage now what
immersive theater this new genre of
theater is trying to do is get you out
of the seat and embodied in the world so
it's the next step all of a sudden you
have agency you can move around you can
interact with the characters the
characters actions can change when they
interact with you the most famous
example of them
Theater is in New York City sleep no
more punch-drunk is the British company
that did this and as far as I'm
concerned
like they cracked it you know the
virtual reality dream of like being in
the movie where you can move around they
did with analog theater so I mean this
is a some kind of hybrid of like
Hitchcock and Macbeth and it takes place
in an abandoned hotel and it's seven
floors and you go in wearing a mask
that's what like distinguishes you from
the actors so all the audience is
wearing these like Eyes Wide Shut styled
masks and the whole thing is super ear
in the stage design and the lighting and
the music is magnificent
you hurled into the world and then the
actors that are sort of dance performing
a version of Macbeth all over the hotel
but you never know from where and how or
when
so you're just lost in this world and
occasionally pieces of performance you
stumble into pieces of performance while
exploring and then you you can follow
the actors around or you cannot but the
feeling is very much like being an
elusive dream you know
yeah and so the idea being that
eventually this kind of immersive
theater where the audience participation
and agency will be combined with things
like augmented or mixed reality
interfaces where you can wear like some
kind of you know maybe the those lenses
that came out that can put digital
artifacts and add elements to that and
then there's also the idea of like fully
immersive virtual reality where you're
sitting in a chair or you're on a
treadmill and you can walk around some
kind of a world but I think that has a
ways to go before it can be as dynamic
as the analog version you just grab the
mic and move it up towards you like you
have a stand yeah perfect just like that
thank you
well I'd say well the first thing I'd
like to ask is I thought this was gonna
be what you were gonna chronologically
show your shots of all we're gonna get
to view it which is not the case so as a
fan will you be willing to do a shot of
like to freestyle something like that in
front of us
the other thing I wanted to say is in
the field of electronic music you can go
anywhere in the universe and as you as a
futurist have you ever thought of maybe
doing a narrative - guided meditation or
thinka tation so that we can view some
type of meditation in your world where
we go into an altered state with maybe
binaural beats that slow our brainwaves
or put us in an all basically here you
there would be a way so you can never do
that
I hear you man um thanks for your
question yeah this was a little bit
different because the format here was
just a fireside chat I have done these
events typically I do like a twenty five
minute talk in combination with the
videos which is great because it
introduces the work to people and it
gives examples of what I'm talking about
we didn't do that this time around but I
mean hopefully the conversation because
it was unscripted give you a sense of
that free style but I loved it to be
here with you is just amazing thanks
thanks for coming and as far as like
recording something that we could you
know like you know nobody's ever done
that I mean a few people have where they
take snippets from either podcast
interviews or some of my videos and they
mix it with electronic music there's a
couple of DJ's that have sent me sets
where they use my voice super cool I've
never done it deliberately in
partnership with somebody but it would
certainly be interesting to do yeah I
mean as far as like in the field of
electronic music I know the best and if
you ever wanted to or not you know you
have to collaborate with me I'd love to
maybe actually writing it a narrative
and saying this is what I'm gonna do and
we're gonna put some music to it well I
mean I have plenty of stuff that uh that
is audio without any post-production
that I could give you yeah and then we
can send it to everybody that came here
came out of this
yeah and my name is Rocco Anthony for
misko and I asked you one time what is
enlightenment to you I don't know if you
remembered but maybe you could tell what
what is enlightenment to you you said
you weren't enlightened but you have
these classical mystical States and you
didn't think they could be you know just
substan like the Buddha talked yeah you
know what it is I've had profoundly
moving and and aesthetically relevant
experiences that have shifted me that
have seemingly transformed me that have
inspired my work and my career which in
turn has inspired others so clearly
there's a digital paper trail that shows
where I have been I mean my my videos
might as well be referred to as trip
reports for sure however I think I'm so
terrified of being disappointed that I
don't cling to the revealed truth of my
videos too strongly I have the
experience I make a video about it and
then typically I I kind of go back into
my baseline of openness but also I avoid
drinking my own kool-aid yeah and and I
think the reason for that is because
there's a terror that I'm like what if I
have one of these moments feels like oh
now I understand how life is I had a
mystical experience and I'm one with
everything and everything is perfect
yeah and then my friend tells me that
his mother had a tumor on her kidney how
am I supposed to like how's that
compatible with a mystical universal
union that I had a day before you know
so it's like it's like I see the
homeless people in San Francisco and
then I'm just like so much suffering on
the street and we ignore em okay
yesterday I was in a beautiful song feel
one with the universe and now I see
people suffering on the street it kind
of negates the oneness I had with the
universe the day before and so that's
why you know my enlightenment always
feels short-lived so far
so but it keeps me humble right because
a lot of people who are enlightened
become overzealous self-righteous gurus
you know and selling false truth you
know and I I think it's more human to
admit that we're full of holes and we
have moments of clarity and insight and
moments of confusion and doubt well I
won't keep these people waiting but yeah
thanks bro how do I collaborate with you
guys just email me through my website
I'm really good like that yeah
all right thanks bro Thanks so I love to
put myself on the edge so I forced
myself to do something that I usually
would which is come up with a question
days before awesome and through those
past two questions it kind of cultivated
a new culture within me to ask this one
which is it kind of seems like the
narrative through all of these talks and
whatnot is solving that kind of
existential angst that we're
collectively having after we solve this
humanistic need and getting into the
frontier of existentialism and what
comes next so really it kind of sounds
like this narrative of the singularity
and whatnot is going towards just
building more of the same the same
bubble almost so when does it get to the
where is the point at which I mean it's
kind of like almost the way that I see
it is building upon building the the
mind but what's beyond that are we just
going to become slaves to the mind of
building connections upon connections
until we become the universe or is there
something more I
I'm not I'm not sure what comes next man
to be honest I you know I think well
Kurzweil certainly thinks the father of
the singularity that we will infuse all
matter with intelligence so at that
point right now kind of intelligence
that we rec seems to be housed in this
amazing three pound flesh computer
called the brain but if we could infuse
everything then it's you know Kurzweil
says the universe will wake up
certainly the beginnings of this right
now we call it the Internet of Things is
a version of extending exterior izing
our minds by infusing everyday objects
with feedback and with intuition and
with artificial intelligence and
creating a world where a lot of the
boundaries between ourselves and the
world start to disintegrate because
we're increasing them to live in a world
that responds to us and they can predict
our needs and it can offer us a drink
when we're thirsty and so when the world
starts to have as much agency as a
highly advanced version of Siri it's
already gonna start to feel like we're
living in a world that lets like a
return to animism like indigenous
cultures would talk to trees and talk to
stones you know it's gonna be digitally
mediated animism the world will sort of
come alive and at some point when the
level and sophistication of the feedback
we get from everyday objects you know
and even in the short term is of a
fidelity that's high enough for us to
respond to it and it responds to us
intuitively will stop asking the
question of whether it really has
consciousness just like we stop asking
that question of each other because I
don't know if any of you guys are fully
conscious and you don't know if I am I
could just be a zombie that's pretending
to be conscious same goes for you guys
but at some point we just suspend
disbelief we just accept the fact that a
person is conscious based on the
intuition of the feedback loops we get
from that person and so I think that's
kind of what will happen like will
impregnate more and more of the world
with with mind is I think that it's kind
of where we're heading if
kind of map our technological trajectory
now whether what that means
metaphysically is up to the poets in the
artist yeah as a poet thank you and yeah
that that fits in right with the idea of
we are a prisoner to every prisoner we
hold in prison because there has to be a
guard for every prisoner
so as we allow the world to be more
conscious than we ourselves will have
more consciousness to experience in the
world thank you I hope so thank you bro
hi I'm Asher thank you so much your time
is amazing Thanks
yeah it's uh I love the way you talk
about Fermi's paradox and I'm like
really interested about paradoxes like I
made this video in college and it was
about me meditating and like
self-actualization and realization of my
true self but the funny thing was is
like I didn't even meditate
really back in college but now I
meditate all the time and so I realized
like oh my god this is like what I was
working towards was this like amazing
space and time where I could become like
you know the singular meditation so I'm
wondering like how do you grapple with
paradox and like how do you make sense
of that paradox like every oscillate
between the the two things that are in
conflict you know what I'm saying like
it's like for me it's paradoxical in a
way that you know we for even like you
know we feel conscious and yet we're
told by neuroscientists that the self is
an illusion you know there's there's
kinds of paradoxes that we grapple with
every day we feel you know at least
young people feel immortal yet we're
told that we are mortal like we live in
doubt you know science has done a really
good job of explaining the world but
then there's new things that emerge that
call into question everything we thought
we knew so we're constantly thrown into
situations where we have to live with
two seemingly contradictory ideas and
somehow live in the presence of both
it's tricky but we do it awesome yeah
thank you so much thank you bro
actually that's one of the hallmarks of
a mystical experiences paradoxic
allottee a feeling that the two
seemingly opposing things suddenly fit
in a larger model of reality that you're
privy to my name is Jay tiny ohm and I
work from apps multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies so
first of all thank you so [ __ ] oh hey
Matt say hi Rick there's a lot of
challenges in the community around the
future of psychedelic medicine there's
approaches that Maps is doing in the
non-profit approach and then there's
for-profit approaches and I was just
wondering fee-only wisdom and how we can
do this work in a way that's conscious
and changing society and and aware of
sort of the social structures that we
live in since you yeah I mean what I
would I've read it Michael Pollan's book
is the the concern about the
medicalization their psychedelics so yes
these controls that we're putting in now
with these studies are important because
we can't afford to risk what happened in
the sixties when the exuberance got so
out of control that we pissed off the
wrong people and it the research was
halted so I think that the careful
approach that they're taking now is good
and the baby steps are similar to what
happens with cannabis at first its
medical but then eventually we got to
recreational I think we can kind of
follow a similar model you know it's
harder for the powers that be to say no
we're not gonna let you use this even
though it's helping people with
treatment resistant depression and
anxiety and so the medicalization
approach I think is a great first step
but what about the idea of making well
people better I mean aren't we all in a
way having like micro PTSD don't we all
suffer from at least a little bit of
depression and anxiety I mean for some
it becomes pathological when they can no
longer function and hold down a job and
so on and so forth but I think the rest
of us are just better at hiding it
you know and so I mean
what happened here when super-successful
achieved people kill themselves all of a
sudden I mean what does that tell you
about the seemingly well-adjusted and
successful so but I think the
medicalization approach is a good first
step and I think eventually it's gonna
be more like you know like going to like
like a spa it'll be like a place that is
licensed with licensed psychotherapist
sand but then aesthetically they can be
whatever you you're into you know it can
be like a jungle spa psychedelic
wellness spa and there can be like a
singularity future is this psychedelic
spa a cosmological psychedelic spa you
know cuz one of the things we've learned
about these medicines is that their
effects are 100% constructed by setting
setting an expectation so you know if
your interpretive frameworks are of one
culture indigenous culture then the
divine will present itself to you in a
particular wallpaper and if you're a
Christian you know it'll present itself
in the form of Jesus and if you're uh
engineer to present itself in the form
of a solution to an engineering problem
and so I think it'll be maybe the
psychedelic spas of the future which
will be will be like restaurants well
you pick your cuisine you know but
they'll all be regulated just like
restaurant food quality we've read you
regulated and and the cooks will have to
be clean and regulating or like I think
maybe that's the answer in the future
you know thank you for your support and
helping make that happen
yes well it's uh the mind is ripe for
exploration and so you know if we can
help alleviate human suffering and learn
a little bit more about consciousness
and treat these things as tools then you
know it's a tool and if used in the
right way it can solve a problem and if
used in the wrong way it can be a weapon
right I mean a hammer can you know be
used to put nails down or it can be used
to hit somebody over the head so it's
how you use the tool
right there so first off thanks for
coming down and talking to us it's been
really interesting listen to what you
got to say amen but what I was thinking
is you were talking earlier about the a
global project to eliminate human
suffering yes we exist in the euphoric
MDMA state now what I was wondering is
do you not think that to some extent
suffering and adversity or a necessary
part of the human condition search for
meaning the arguably having things like
bliss and euphoria unhappiness might not
even be possible without the angst and
the depression and the suffering the
counterpoint that with that's a
fantastic question and I'm actually I'm
actually inclined to agree with you at
an insight the other day my friend he's
super excited because he got a Tesla and
he was we went to like a road where he
could like accelerate a little bit to
show me like to pick up with her and you
know hit it
whoo that initial feeling of
acceleration is like a reverse dolly
shot in a film is you can liken it to
the moment when a character is having a
realization where his reality has
shifted from one to another so again
back to your notion of contrasts you
know the reverse dolly shot in the movie
works because you're temporarily
disjointed and disoriented as you move
again from one perspective to another
through the eyes of this character
acceleration takes you from one speed to
another once you reach a velocity you
don't feel the speed anymore really it's
only during the acceleration which is
the shift from one to the other so
perhaps you are right perhaps ecstasy is
more meaningful after having overcome
adversity no doubt you know that's why
there's a thrill of the chase and then
there's the thrill of attaining what it
is you were chasing and then you have to
start again because once you get what
you want the game is over so but maybe
these are things that we can build and
design into our life projects whether
they happen in the flesh world or in
virtual reality you know I still think
we can eliminate the suffering of
illness and the unnecessary suffering of
people starving and that kind of
suffering I don't think that that's
necessary to give our lives meaning I
think we can maybe inject artificial
dramatic suffering just like a good
movie has conflict
but without having to have people die of
cancer or horrendous other painful
diseases thank you very much cheers man
hi upon everything that you said I I
want to hear yours so upon an evolution
I wanna ask what if whenever we feel or
there's part of our brain that lights up
and in the happenstance of the virtual
reality then it always got gets turned
on gets turned on but so what I'm saying
is what would that how would that affect
evolution so upon the over axis of the
turning on of the earth that fuels have
then the thing that virtual reality
would induce would lead to an evolution
of turning off I'm not sure if what
you're asking is this but I think are
you saying that if we figure out a way
with our tools and technologies whether
it's virtual reality or other strategies
to give ourselves experiences of awe on
a more regular basis if then that will I
guess over many many many generations
transform us because we are using the
part of the brain that registers all
more often is that what you're asking I
think it might take a long time no it's
not
sorry okay so let me explain it first so
upon your thinking process what is the
part of our brain that hugo saw will
always be turned on and thus inducing
the other parts of her head ever
evolving into a smaller form so the
other parts of our brain would atrophy
because we're not using them as much I
mean III think it would have to be many
many many many generations before our
brain showed like some physiological
change due to more exposure to AH I'm
not a scientist so I can't explain that
as accurately as I would like but thank
you for well the base line going up and
then what happens after that it but that
base line would have to be engineered to
get different that's different than just
evolution having you selecting for a
different baseline you know David Pearce
advocates intervening going in there and
changing [ __ ] anyway hi Jason hey I
understand yeah great question um what's
your opinion for those that don't know
like Venezuela is collapsing it's
basically a failed state inflation is
like at a million percent this year the
government is basically a narco-state
they've censored all the media they've
arrested all political dissidents they
rigged the elections they've turned down
humanitarian assistance for the people
who are starving and can't get access to
medicine but they wear this banner of
fighting for some like Cuban style
socialist dream with no freedom for
citizens of course and they've basically
pillaged and raped the country the
corrupt government in the history of the
country and so being from there and you
know seeing firsthand what has happened
I think that we need a bunch of nations
to get together and send armies in bro
[Laughter]
how would you say that the sort of
Internet of Things and the extension of
our mind in VR has affected culture in
the way that we sort of interact with
each other we'd see that again
how would you sort of say that the
internet and the extension of our own
collective minds into a digital space
has actually affected our interactions
with one another not purely on a digital
realm so you think that because we spend
so much of our time interfacing with
screens how has that affected how we
interface with each other yeah I think
it can be argued both ways you know I
think people love to say oh we never pay
attention to what's in front of us
because we're always on our phone but
nobody ever stops to ask if maybe what's
on our phone is more interesting than
what's in front of us a large amount of
the time you know like I mean sometimes
you are watching an astounding video on
YouTube and you're uncomfortable commute
in the subway in New York and the heat
to work and rather than staring at other
miserable angry folks you'd rather watch
some amazing video to take you out of
your head to make the commute a little
bit less miserable and that's an example
of like hell yeah give me some escape
but maybe other examples is like you
know you're at a park by yourself
there's a lovely lady there with her dog
by herself and you don't notice each
other because you're both on your phone
oh well that's too you know so it can be
argued it can be argued both ways man
see it's hard for me to pick a side
because I think it's all contextual you
know there are some ways you know I owe
you all be inspired by my work is thanks
to this you know but the problem with
this is also when this
comes at the expense of not leaving room
for face-to-face moments that are
meaningful I think it just it just puts
the responsibility back in our shoulders
I think to self curate how we deploy
these tools you know that's okay for now
hi Jason
Hey I was impressed by the early
discussion about romance and well I
don't know I just wanted to thank you
for that human moment part way through
where you were talking about like
gathers that there's the pain and the
agony of it sort of part of it as the
meaning and it's all intertwined but um
I mean even even before you ask you a
question you say to that because you
know I this is something that I used to
do a lot I haven't done it as much
anymore and maybe because I've lost my
tolerance for pain but when I was I've
made videos all my life I really have
you know now I make videos of love and I
put some stock footage of generic humans
that aren't directly related to me but I
used to basically make those same videos
and then the cutaways were to my
girlfriend you know and when I was
deeply deeply deeply in love that was
intertwined with obsessive documentation
I was constantly recording what it was
like to be in that interest subjective
space and then I was looking for words
to describe that ecstasy and I would
take that footage and then I would edit
it with the most heart-wrenching ly
agonizingly sad and beautiful melody I
could find and lay that underneath and
then review the footage even from the
day before of me and this girl I was in
love with right and what was amazing is
within two seconds something that was 24
hours ago was made so poignant I was
like I felt like I had lost this person
even though they were still in my life
and it was in mimicking the feeling of
loss that it made me appreciate them
more before I lost them so in a way it
was like jolting myself into realizing
house
it is to be in love with somebody and it
required an aesthetic act to bring
attention to it I needed to make the
video I needed to put it to sad music
you guys ever see the movie lala land
the end montage of lala land the dream
ballet that replays the whole movie with
beautiful music and all the images is
what could have been which should have
been what might have been that poignant
feeling of looking back that melancholic
sadness and it shatters you and the
reason it shatters you is because it
makes you realize how much you didn't
fully appreciate what you had and I
think that that's always been the
tension and the dance that I've had with
love it's like I created artificial
suffering as a way of making me more
present and appreciative of what I had
yes you know and maybe it's because my
intuition knew that nothing lasts
forever and I was like well I'd rather
grieve while I still have them because
then I can actually hug them in the
midst of that sad ecstasy rather than
wait until they're actually gone and cry
by myself
weird [ __ ] I've been doing but that's
what I would do and I haven't even
gotten to my question well I was struck
by what you were saying with regard to
having several solutions to the problem
of death to putting away the anxiety and
the discomfort that comes with the
notion that you will eventually die much
that you care about as well and religion
being one solution love being another
solution and creative pursuits being a
third solution or the pursuit of flow in
particular and I mean you when you
describe flow and you describe creative
pursuits and creative states you use
much of the same language that you might
use to describe romance much of the same
intensity much of the same all and the
kind of question I have is basically
that in noting that it's clearly the
case that you can't sustain the second
solution for well you know one's entire
life or even just more than 12 months
you know it's essentially
insensible to to rely on that but maybe
you can you can use the similarity
between these things and and it's like
the sustainability of creative ecstasy
is something you can repeatedly call it
into being right it's not something that
our tendency to be awed by creative
experience doesn't just diminish after
three months it goes in cycles you can
always get it back you just need a
recovery phase you know after deep deep
deep flow I might take like a day or two
where I just need to chill but the flow
cycles yeah as long as you follow the
rules of the psycho cycle and you pay
attention to your biochemistry
potentially yeah you could have flow
until you die you know but in the cycles
you know just not on the high the whole
time but go on right which makes it a
particularly powerful third solution yes
maybe my Russian is what is your opinion
on pursuing a kind of synthesis of
relative love repeatedly engaging in
creative pursuits mutualist like in a
mutual relationship with other people as
a way to sustain so you just provided
the solution no no no see what you've
said right now I just got the goosebumps
because it's you know I think the whole
thing in life as far as mental health is
concerned is DIY right like we're all
[ __ ] trying to figure it out and the
jazz musician has a solution the
basketball player has a solution the
surfer has a solution I mean they're all
the Bodhisattvas telling you this is the
way my son learn how to surf this wave
learn how to box get a workout in like
everybody's promising you the the thing
the flow the hide ah but there are
certain things that tend to constantly
trigger it well no matter what type of
flow is what the activity specifically
gets you the flow there's a universal
flow trigger which is novelty so a new
experience tends to put you into flow
even if you hadn't decided if that's
your activity that you love doing but
but in fact that it's new will probably
be a flow trigger so I have always
thought if you combine let's say travel
with a relationship you could probably
renew the excitement of meeting them for
the first time by changing the backdrop
instead of having to change the person
you change the backdrop and the person
comes into view again because of the
flow induced by travel and then if you
want to even be more DIY well you know
then you know you add a little bit of an
intoxicant here and there to italicize
the experience you know some cannabis
take it sounds like you're offering an
enticing opportunity for the next
contender dude it's gonna be like oh my
god we have to go travel the world I
mean hasn't that always been the dream
as you want to like see a sunset like
sitting on a sailboat in some like
remote island like the halo of the now
dude
the sacred timeless moment the moment
that exists outside of time right Golden
Hour veneer again if music be the food
of love play on Wow
so I was had a similar question to him
about you seemed like you go into these
relationships thinking they're gonna end
or that they have an end and you haven't
maybe found like that person where you
feel like it's that forever and how
would you imagine creating with that
person you know to is not really stable
whereas that third that gives stability
and normally you croak co-create which
is typically a baby but what if it were
like a project uh you know passion
project together and that would be yeah
well I think in some ways I would say
that that sort of assumption or that
relationship with endings and finitude
is something that people come to terms
with at different times in their lives
you know some people maybe don't
experience it until they're on their
deathbed and lucky them
they lived in the present the whole time
they never worried that things were
gonna end until they fully ended but
still they had a lot of bliss throughout
I think that your expectations and your
assumptions about finitude are
determined by early childhood
experiences right because when you're a
child you live in the Garden of Eden
when you're a child you live outside of
time that's kind of what's wonderful
about the childlike consciousness and
you know I remember my mom told me this
story that uh you know we lived in
Venezuela so when we go to the US like
twice a year one of the exciting things
about going to the US if you go to the
toy store you know they didn't have toys
stores like that have been as well I
like Toys R Us and and so but maybe
because I was learning I learned from a
young age that you know we only go to
the US twice a year and then therefore
we're only there for a short amount of
time before we go back to Venezuela and
so there's only a certain amount of days
that you can go to the toy store so I go
to the toy store and I used to get
anxiety going in because I'm so
overwhelmed by all the options then I go
back to my mom you like can we stay here
infinite time because I already had like
a relationship with the tension that
like I couldn't be there indefinitely
and you know that clearly stems from
something in my childhood I don't know
if it was the early divorce of my
parents you know or just an acutely
sensitive kid that asks too many
questions about the way of things but
certainly there was a realization a
shattering of the Garden of Eden early
on and and and and I think it has to do
also with feeling unsafe at an early age
right because when you're young you're
supposed to be made to feel completely
protected which is the illusion of
eternity your parents are gods and
goddesses you live outside of time
they're omnipotent and you live in a
gated paradise you know that keeps the
chaos at bay but any type of illness at
an early age of a parent or a divorce or
anything that shatters that important
illusion to make you a well-adjusted
person with low levels of neurotic
ism if that is shattered that's the
beginning of pathology you know it's
it's it's it's the waking up into hell
so to speak and then you spend the rest
of your life trying to recapture that
feeling of feeling safe and feeling held
and feeling protected it's like what
drug what trip what person what piece of
art can return me to that feeling you
know so it's like you know I wouldn't be
Who I am and done the work that I have
done I guess if things would have been
different but it's also meant a lot of a
lot of trials and tribulations along the
way okay
Alexis I'll flow Vienna differente
cuando uno ala in glioma
that's also true she's saying that flow
is easier in your native tongue is Tamil
exponentially ayahuasca in ceremonial I
have they heard ayahuasca they got
excited I'm gonna try to answer that
well the short answer is I have not
drank ayahuasca I know that it's become
very trendy as of late Carl Jung has a
great line about in Theo genex and which
is why I think that the highly
controlled way in which they're doing it
in these trials with psilocybin and
stuff are the way to go he says beware
of unearned wisdom okay and Jordan
Peterson quoted Carl Jung would ask the
same question
beware of unearned wisdom because you
might be you might not be a vessel that
can handle that divine fluid it's like
the Ark of the Covenant right yeah God
is in there but if you look at it you
die you know so I just think that is
their healing to be found in plant
medicine no doubt
that's why civilizations for millennia
have employed these tools but they also
had very fixed containers for them and I
think people getting together in a
Brooklyn apartment with some shaman
tourists they brought from Brazil who's
giving everybody I don't I just don't
know if that ticks the boxes of a safe
container and I worry about the
irresponsible use because I think in the
desire to heal trauma these medicines
can also cause trauma and and so even
though I'm Pro research a hundred
percent I am NOT Pro casual when it
comes to this stuff
hi so much thank you I kind of don't
even know where to begin
Oh Ruth but I guess in the interest of
keeping it short and focusing on
suffrage and full incoming well-rounded
with plant medicine discussing I you ask
a relationship to self intrinsic
behavior how your body responds responds
what's going on from the outside
speaking about Michael Pollan and food
and the interest of AI and what the goal
is I mean they're looking at AI now for
treatment for pain because we're not
understanding where pain is actually
coming from but we understand that if
we're an AI or if we're in psychedelics
then we're gonna be developing neural
pathways we're gonna be training our
body we're gonna be creating this
delicious response
hence through structure and guidance
that we can find some tangible traction
to ease the suffrage hence suffrage I'm
a huge plant-based person and I'm very
interested in the human relationship to
toxin toxin development calcification of
the pineal gland the lack of
acknowledgment to the psoas muscle which
is our intrinsic response to fright and
flight and terror so if the glass is
gonna fall my so as is telling me first
catch the glass but nobody's paying
attention to the psoas muscle and it
continues to go away now I get this
isn't the context in the space to do it
and I'm really excited about AI I get to
be a TechCrunch this year in San
Francisco for some crazy stuff it's just
like part of the future at the exact
same time we have to pay attention to
our food we have to pay attention to
what is causing our system to sleep and
to be quiet to need the need of AI when
our body is in suffrage when we eat the
food that we are given to eat the first
place of suffrage we have is X fixie
ation you like movies and get it
forgive me coz I'm on the mic they have
the goblet you take the cyanide no you
take the syenite now who's gonna die
first
Oh guess what we both have it I've just
been building up my body's protection to
this so in the relationship to toxicity
and food how do we find access to this
when most of this stuff causes our body
to sleep causes us to be debilitated it
causes the disease the cancer and the
pain on top of the emotional aspect of
why do people have breast cancer well
most women have breast cancer because
high we bear the burden of the world and
we have these two nectars that provide
and it encases our heart my heart is
breaking on her can't handle it so it
moves the energy from your heart it puts
it to your breast where it can be
disseminated where it actually gets
touch where it actually gets
acknowledged where it actually gets all
of so in short I don't know if there's a
question but I think no I think you
thank you for sharing yeah intrinsic and
connected and we want to be connected
and we want to sit with a medicine plant
but you can't sit with plant and toxin
right so yeah let's have people work out
a way that we can have these things to
support this but if we're supporting it
through the dissemination of toxins
which is gonna stagnate our liver which
is gonna mess up our kidneys which is
gonna screw our adrenals which is gonna
make women have thyroid problems crazy
with the lack of wheat like I know you
know so what she got brah come to
Oakland no I'm kidding
thank you hi Jason my name is Marcel I'm
from Brazil
Amy I'd like to ask you a more sober
question it's a little bit off-topic and
what was discussed here but I really
would like to hear your thoughts in
regards to the duality that now we have
so much access to material things and I
think most of all of us here in this
room would say they're living a
comfortable life compared to others and
I think San Francisco is the perfect
example of this duality how do you feel
I just love to hear your thoughts in
regard to this perspective that we're
constantly looking for success trying to
reach our best and have those happiness
moments working on these companies you
know driving these cars and doing all
this stuff while at the same time seeing
so much poverty so much people needing
your help and at the same time having to
suffocate that inner soul that screams
help this guy in the street right and
I'll say I'm a hypocrite I would say
that well no but I mean why do you feel
about having to suffocate those feelings
in our soul to help those people at the
same time human soul not empowered to do
anything because that's it's just a big
problem in the bigger scale thank you
yeah no I think the feeling is one of
total impotence and it's a I think that
empathy rarely extends beyond our line
of sight so I think the solution for
most people is just not to look there
whether consciously or unconsciously
another coping strategy even though it's
true but it's still a coping strategy is
to tell yourself the world is better
than it's ever been
yes they're suffering but there's a lot
less than there used to be and hundreds
of millions of people leave poverty
every day it's just maybe not happening
at the rate in America but certainly in
Southeast Asia and other places people
are leaving poverty at a rapid rapid
rapid rate we don't live there we don't
see it but all in all human progress is
astounding by
remeasure Belinda cater so you know you
walk down the street you see a homeless
person you're like how is it possible
this is so horrible it's so sad you feel
impotent
maybe you tell yourself that like
overall things are getting better
certainly doesn't help that person but
it helps you to feel less guilty we
don't continue to walk and do your thing
I think that's what people do right what
else can they do
unless you've said that you can help
that one person but then what about the
150 million that you're not helping so I
mean I suffer the same way with this as
you and every time I see a person that
doesn't seem well it feels like all of
my concerns and ambitions and goals are
called into question and seem
meaningless and I mean you feel like a
hypocrite I mean I share with you that
sensation and and I don't really have a
solution you know I I mean I don't I I
struggle with that yeah daily yeah I'm
just saying that there's a we get to
wrap Q&A up yeah we got a wrap QA oh
thank you thank you thank you very much
guys thank you
[Applause]